what exactly has Johnson Johnson been
accused of in many cases there's a long
legal history here yeah so Johnson &
Johnson has been accused of knowing of
studies that suggested there's a link
between using baby powder genitally and
ovarian cancer and that they've never
put a warning on the label and what is
Johnson Johnson said in return indeed
there have been many of these cases
plaintiffs have won some others have
been they haven't won others so what
said what if they send response what's
the company says so Johnson Johnson
defends the safety of talcum powder
which is what baby powder is made of
says that it has known about the studies
but concluded that whatever association
there is is weak that the data was
flawed and that they feel very confident
in continuing to sell it without a
warning label I mean it's an absolutely
fascinating story Susan and a
gut-wrenching tragic one as well and
give us a sense of what's heading to
court
instant lewis when we understand that
there's going to be a hearing coming up
in the next month yes so next month
there's a woman who is 62 years old and
was diagnosed with ovarian cancer a
couple years ago and had used baby
powder for 20 years and she like the
other women before her claiming that no
Johnson and Johnson's cert have at least
put a warning on the label then women
are free to make a choice but that they
didn't know and now they're suing the
company there was an earlier case in st.
Louis in the end of February which
prompted this story and in that case the
woman had died before the case came to
trial but her family was awarded 72
million dollars yeah it's amazing
articulated in your story of the tragedy
and indeed the son he seemed to break
into tears when he got that award but
tell us about what this will means for
Johnson and Johnson because they have
really cashed in on the branding of the
talcum powder of the baby element and
the fact that it can be used by anyone
and everyone how much is this going to
hurt their bottom line yeah so you know
Johnson & Johnson has been selling baby
powder almost since the company started
and it's really the foundation for their
baby business and also you know for
their image as right the baby company
you know we all know the products that
they say
so I think this hurts it from its image
but it doesn't necessarily have an
impact on its bottom line yet
you know the awards are sizable
certainly for the families but not you
know not by Johnson & Johnson standards
but I think the greater the greater
potential harm to the company comes from
what people think about you know a
company that's being accused of hiding
some fairly important information from
its customers do you have a sense if
there's any sort of debate within the
company you have some signs indicating
that in fact this may be carcinogenic
you have the company here saying that's
not the kind of overall saying that it's
not is there a debate going on within
Johnson Johnson you think over how it
should proceed as these cases come up
you know I don't know the real answer to
that what you know what I can say is
probably any company in a position like
this would have to be having some kind
of discussion and I think it really
depends ultimately who prevails you know
is it the lawyers you know is it the
executives is it the scientist is it the
marketers you know who now have a
problem on their hands all right Susan
thank you so much that's Bloomberg
Businessweek you can read her latest
story in the latest issue of Bloomberg
Businessweek on newsstands and online